listen as i said in the other interviews
i'm going to commend universal on the
map paintings because that's amazing
behind cause we're in denver right now
right 100 it's pretty crazy though uh
that we're in malta talking about the
extended edition which i'm just gonna
say and is like the superior version of
the movie it is um it's it it adds so
much what are you most excited for
people to actually see in it i'm excited
about in a very holistic way because
that's uh you know it was the movie for
a long time and until a very uh late
moment in the process and so uh i've
always seen it as the movie and and the
film that was released in theaters is
you know the movie with pieces removed
as opposed to this being you know the
movie with pieces added and i think it's
an important distinction to make because
i think we're used to seeing director's
cuts uh which this isn't technically uh
although it kind of is it's sort of hard
to put it into a box but uh to me i i
think that the way that this film starts
and ends to be able to see the real
beginning of the movie to see it travel
over 65 million years and to put the
whole thing in context uh to me it makes
it more powerful one of the things that
i actually respect about universal with
this edition is usually they make people
double dip right and i like the fact
that maybe you want to say it oh yeah
not only uh are we not you know
releasing this two years from now is
something else you have to buy but if
you bought the movie already on itunes
or uh you know on vod uh the extended
edition is you it will just show up you
don't have to pay more for that which i
think is that's a cool move you
mentioned that this was your original
cut um until very late in the process
right uh what was like in the editing
room for you like having to like sort of
pull out sequences was there like did
you have to hit a certain
like there are some
bugs around here no what is that what's
it called
wow all right well very loud anyone
who's watching this interview now
understands that there are some real
bugs in malta that sounds a lot this is
not adr this is you know watching watch
out for bugs right so but getting into
what i was saying what was it like in
the process for you as a director was it
something like you had to hit a certain
run time what was it like for you that
uh it was the hardest thing i ever had
to do um it was uh you know they say you
have to kill your darlings uh and that
is a
something that
anyone who gets into into film needs to
be prepared to to think uh that way
about their film to understand uh that
there may be things that need to go in
order to streamline it in a way uh
obviously it was something uh that i i
wish i didn't have to do
but uh the movie needed to be two and a
half hours it was already much longer
than any other jurassic movie you know
by a good 20 minutes uh and so
sitting in there and figuring out what
could go without sacrificing people
understanding even what's going on in
like a fundamental way
uh was really the challenge uh
and you know yeah in the end hopefully
this is the kind of thing that you know
if you do want to be a filmmaker you can
and you saw the theatrical version uh
you can watch the original film and and
maybe understand some of the sacrifices
you have to make some of the compromises
you have to make as a filmmaker because
it is a relationship i didn't pay for
this movie i didn't release it all
around the world uh and you know that's
something that you have to understand
this franchise is a huge thing for
universal these movies make a billion
dollars um and merchandise and the toys
what do you think actually going forward
for the franchise um what do you think
the studio might want to do or what
would you do if you were continuing
you know it's it's i think what
we're adam moments uh
that i think the franchise was at you
know eight or nine years ago where a set
of stories have been told and
this 37 year old guy came into steven
spielberg and said listen like
check this out like i i see a path and
here's a story in a beginning middle of
an end and i i think that we can turn
this into something that is different
than what it was which is that it's not
a a bunch of movies uh with plots about
dinosaurs it's a movie about movie about
people who live in a world in which
there are dinosaurs and that's an
important distinction for me marvel
tells stories that are not about
superheroes they're about people in a
world in which they're superheroes and
that was the most important thing for me
is to make that transition so that when
a younger filmmaker comes in whoever
comes in now and has a vision they're
able to have a vision within this new
construct and i think they're the
breadth of stories the diversity of
stories and experiences we can have in
the new world we've created is going to
be an advantage to that filmmaker do you
think that the studio amblin would ever
allow jurassic world to make a lower
budget
r-rated movie in the jurassic world
universe or do you think it's kind of
permanently in pg-13 because so many
kids love the dinosaurs you know it's
hard to answer that question i don't
know i i do know that if we you know if
we made a quiet place you know if we
made a hard r you know a really really
scary version potentially very contained
i know i'd want to see that movie um if
a parent took their kid to that movie
and and horrified them for life i know
that would be a problem uh look i i
don't want to put any cuffs on whoever
uh you know has a vision for this in the
future i think that well all i know is
that people love dinosaurs people love
movies with dinosaurs in them uh and i i
i know people uh
love the world that michael crichton
created the reason why there are
dinosaurs and humans in the same place
that's sci-fi idea it's a brilliant idea
from there i feel like someone else
should come to us
you've spent the last decade making
jurassic world movies being in the
dinosaur business if you will this is
your first time not having a jurassic
thing in front of you what is it like as
a filmmaker are you nervous are you
excited like about the future i mean i
am and i mean as we both know like you
know
everything i have made over the past
nine years um has been in the context of
or the shadow of two major franchises uh
that we loved when we were kids and to
have to to to be a storyteller an
original storyteller and present
something
without it being able to get out of that
shadow
has been challenging for me and so to be
able to now step out of it
and i know it makes me vulnerable in a
different kind of way as an artist but
to go and and tell stories without it
constantly being in the context of you
know from the guy responsible for making
new versions of the thing that you loved
when you were a child uh you know that's
liberating in a way i'll be honest i
think that the multi-action set piece in
dominion is fantastic but i'm more
impressed with it actually now having
been in malta and seeing how thin the
streets are
this is like it's
a small car has a tough time on a road
let alone filming a big sequence what i
mean can you sort of explain to people
the challenge of that sequence yeah i
thank you um i mean it's a testament to
all the stunt drivers and and the stunt
men and women uh here uh dan bradley
who's extraordinary second unit director
has done some of the most amazing bond
sequence steve scene and uh we worked so
closely together to figure out how we
were going to pull it off it's funny
because the thing that inspired it for
me was ronin uh you know it was an
amazing car chase through those you know
those tight little alleys and how tight
the walls are it's like you're in a
trench the whole time and then while we
were doing it i was like how the hell
did they do ronin like with you know how
did they do it uh no i mean it was
extremely challenging but i think that's
the reason why it feels so visceral and
kind of nasty and dirty and it doesn't
feel like we did it on a sound stage or
with a green screen at all everything
you see is real except for the dinosaurs
on that note i'm really happy audiences
are going to get to see the extended cut
thank you so much for your time
you